يعقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه مغلقه مساء
اليوم الاثنين يتلقى خلالها اعضاء المجلس
احاطه من وكيل الامين العامه للامم
المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه
الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا وسيشارك مندوبات
تركيا وسوريا لدى الامم المتحده في الجلسه
المغلقه وستليها جلسه مشاورات مغلقه اخرى
يناقش خلالها اعضاء المجلس فقط التطورات
وكيفيه الاستجابه تاتي الجلسه في ظل تعبير
الامين العام للامم المتحده عن امله في ان
يتم السماحه للامم المتحده باستعمال معبر
حدودي اخر بالاضافه الى معبر باب الهوى
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى سوريا
ذلك قالت المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده ليندا توماس في بيان ان الولايات
المتحده تدعو مجلس الامن الدولي الى
التصويت الفوري على السماح بارسال مساعده
دوليه الى شمال غربي سوريا الخاضع لسيدرات
المعارضه عبر مزيد من المعابر الحدوديه من
تركيا وعقلت جرين فيلدن كل ساعه لها
اهميتها في الوقت الحالي وان النسب في
المناطق المتضرره بشمال غربي سوريا
يعتمدون علينا من جهه اخرى نقلت رويترز عن
متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت
الابيض انه يجب السماح بدخول جميع
المساعدات الانسانيه الى شمال غربي سوريا
عبر جميع المعابر الحدوديه واضاف المتحدث
وانه يتعين توزيع المساعدات على جميع
المناطق المتضرره دون تاخير على حد قوله
للمتابعه تنضم الي من واشنطن مراسله
الجزيره بسان ابو كويك مرحبا بيسان هل
يمكن اعتبار هذه التصريحات التي جاءت
متسقه في وقت واحد من الطرف الامريكي ضوء
اخضر لما قد يعلن عنه في الاجتماع المرتقب
لمجلس الامن الدولي
ربما محمد ولكن طبعا هذه التصريحات
الامريكيه هي ذاتها التي نسمعها من
الاداره الامريكيه منذ وقوع الزلزال قبل
اسبوع من اليوم
وما قاله المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
لي رويترز بان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
كان واضحا بان الولايات المتحده
ستقوم وستسهل كل ما تستطيع ان القيام به
من اجل ايصال المساعدات
لسوريا وطبعا تاتي هذه الدعوه الى سوريا
اي النظام وجميع الاطراف لاتاحه وصول
المساعدات وعبر كافه المعابر الى كافه
المناطق المتضرره دون استثناء ياتي ذلك
طبعا بعد تقرير من رويترز نقلا عن مصدر من
احدى المجموعات على الجانب الاخر يعني
فعليا في شمال غربي سوريا بان هناك
قضيه متعلقه بالموافقات تعرقل وصول
المساعدات ويعني وفق ذلك المصدر
انهم لن يسمحوا لنظام الاسد بالاستفاده من
خلال ادخال هذه المستعات والاظهار بانه
يقوم هو بنفسه
بالمساعده لذا هي قضيه ربما تثير عده
مواقف الان ولكن الموقف الامريكي تحديدا
هو ان على الجميع وجميع الاطراف اتاحه
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه خصوصا الى شمال
غربي سوريا وطبعا واشنطن كانت قد يعني او
الاداره الامريكيه تحديدا
سئلت عده مرات الاسبوع الماضي حول قضيه
العقوبات
والموقف الامريكي كان ان نعم هناك عقبات
ولكن العقوبات المفروض على نظام الاسد
ليست من بين هذه العقبات ومن ثم قامت
الخزانه الامريكيه باصدار ترخيص طارق يعفي
من يريد ارسال مساعدات الى سوريا من اي
عقوبات وهذا امر تشدد عليه الاداره
الامريكيه بان العقوبات ليست عقبه في طريق
المساعدات الانسانيه وانه يجب تسهيل
ايصالها وسمعنا من طبعا
السفير الامريكيه في الامم المتحده ليندا
توماس سكرين فيلد تدعو الى تصويت مجلس
الامن على فتح معابر اضافيه لايصال
المساعدات وهذا ربما ايضا يتصق مع تصريحات
سابقه لامين عام الامم المتحده الذي كان
قد اعرب فيها عن امله عن معبر اضافي
بالاضافه الى معبر باب الهوى من اجل ايصال
المساعدات الى شمال غربي سوريا محمد شكرا
جزيلا بسبب كويك مراسله الجزيره كنت معي
من واشنطن